بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين
والصلاه والسلام على رسوله الكريم وعلى
اله واصحابه اجمعين
واشهد ان لا اله الا الله وحده لا شريك له
هو يتولى الصالحين
واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله
اللهم صل على محمد وعلى ال محمد كما صليت
على ابراهيم وعلى ال ابراهيم انك حميد
مجيد اللهم بارك على محمد وعلى ال محمد
كما باركت على ابراهيم وعلى ال ابراهيم
في العالمين انك حميد مجيد
اما بعد
ترا ان شاء الله تعالىable
will
have a kind
of prop صلى الله عليه وسلم
somees of theران
‏which we are in
dire need of hearing and contemplating.
I've chosen a book regarding a subject
that often unfortunately goes overlooked
or is often viewed as being a given
something that you know we already know
this.
‏are
this particular and that has to be
learned you have to go out to learn
notend
ander
الفقه الاكبر
[Silence]
الله سبحانه وتالى
আল্লাহ
ابو حنيفه رحمه
[Silence]
الفقه الاكبر
فقه
توحيد الله سبحانه وتعالى
فق
‏et
ma
understand
الله سبحانه وتالى
الله
سبحانه وتعالى
اسلام الصلاه والزكاه والصيام والحج
ان شاء الله
20 minut 15 minut
we have to go back to the purpose of our
existence
why we created
why do we ex
you know a that oftentimes
we as musls might even take for grant
because we
‏to
ag that other go through because have
answer to question they don't know why
they can you
can you try to gra with this life and
difficulties ‏and
and its horors or hardships or crises
having to grapple with all of that yet
you do not know why you were created who
created you and who you belong to where
you are going and these are the three ma
question
‏propets and messengers they come to
answer those three major question they
are fundamental they are the most ma
question that
present themselves to us as human beings
who am i
am i and who do i bel to ‏those three
questions and
you see that human beings are very good
at surrounding themselves with noise
with noise fun activities and alcohol
and
entertainment and just anything to take
our minds of this butentually
the noise is going to sle and you have
to face the silence
‏Why do I
do
why all
that question
to us through the Quran
the same answer given in many different
ways
سهريات
الله سبحانه وتعالى
وما خلقت الجن والانس الا ليعبدون
ليعبدون هنا بحذف ياء المتكلم
و
الكسره على النون دلاله على الياء
المحذوفه اي وما خلقت الجن والانس الا
ليعبدوني
ما اريد منهم من رزق وما اريد ان يطعمون
ان يطعموني
الله سبحانه وتعالى
‏allى
why
الله الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
الله سبحانه وتعالى
سوره الذاريات وما خلقت الجن والانس الا
ليعبدون
يقول تعالى ولقد بعثنا في كل امه رسولا ان
اعبدوا الله واجتنبوا الطاغوت
الله سبحانه وتعالى ساز
وير من سوره النحل
ولقد بعثنا في كل امه
رسولا ان اعبدوا الله
ان هنا المخففه تفسيريه
اي ابتعثه الله تعالى رسولا
ويفسر رسالته فيقول يقول اعبدوا الله
واجتنبوا الطاغوت
ما هو الطاغوت؟
الطاغوت
هذه كلمه تتكرر في كتاب الله ما معناها؟
ماخوذ من الطغيان
والطغيان
مجاوزه الحد اذا تجاوز الشيء حده
فان العرب تصفه
بالطغيان
يقول الله تعالى انا لما طغى الماء
حملناكم في الجاريه
لما طغى الماء اي لما تجاوز الماء حد
المنفعه
الى حد الضرر واصبح مهلكا حملناكم
ايها ايها الناس في ظهر ابيكم نوح عليه
السلام في الجاريه اي في السفينه
فالطغيان هو مجاوزه الحد والطاغوت
هو كما وصفه
ابن القيم رحمه الله تعالى بقوله الطاغوت
هو كل ما تجا جاوز به العبد حده
من معبود او متبوع او مطاع
هذا هو تعريف الطاغوت
يقول تعالى ان اعبدوا الله واجتنبوا
الطاغوت ما هو الطاغوت
هو كل ما تجاوز به العبد حده
من معبود الاصنام
ما عبد من دون الله هذا طاغوت
او متبوع
ان يتبع غير الرسل في تحريم ما احل الله
او تحليل ما حرم الله
هذا طاغوت او مطاع ان يطيع غير الله
سبحانه وتعالى في معصيه الله فانه قد اتخذ
اخذ هذا الشيء او هذا الشخص فقد اتخذه
طاغوتا
فالطاغوت
يطلق ويراد به جميع
ما يتجاوز به العبد حده الشرعي
الله سبحانه وتعالى
سوره النحل
‏naion
الله
سبحانه وتعالى
اعبدوا الله
واجتنبوا الطاغوت
الله
anyلا
اله الا الله
و لا اله الا الله
لا اله اي لا معبود
بحق الا الله
وهنا
اعبدوا الله واجتنبوا الطاغوت
لا اله الا
لا اله الا الله
might offend
beed
offered as to them ‏People think you
know Muslim been Muslim all my
lifehallah
that's easy stuff got that in the back
already understand that why would I need
to go back and study this as if any
part of the Quran
is trivial let alone
that which makes us or break us
a person can meet
‏fall into any form
الله سبحانه وتالى
لا اله الا
‏for
الا الله
over
to
knowledable to ‏or that subject
that is the subject of subjects
without understanding this perfect and
reviewing it all of the time all of our
lives then we place ourselves inanger
listen to whatahيم
says the schم
عليه
was
100 years old
ابراهيم عليه السلام
اسماعيل
الله
اللهم
دعاء
وجنبني وبني ان نعبد
الاصنام
ابراهيم عليه السلام
الله
خلي الله
سبحانه وتعالى
ابو الانبياء
ابراهيم
وجنبني وبني ان نعبد الاصنام
الله
ابراهيم
‏id
life
ابراهيم النقعي رحمه الله تعالى فمن يامن
على نفسه الشرك بعد ابراهيم
شحم
لا اله الا الله
لا اله الا
يقول الامام احمد ابن حنبل رحمه الله
تعالى
يقول بئس قوم ابو جهل اعلم منهم بكلمه لا
اله الا
ابو جهل
لا اله الا الله
صلى الله عليه
‏of
الا الله
[Silence]
implication
لا اله الا
لا اله الا الله
God
الله
why would
they neverev
other
الله سبحانه وتالى says
صلى الله عليه وسلم
ولا سالتهم من خلق السماوات والارض ليقول
الله
محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم ابو جهل ابو لهب
ابو سفيان
بنفيه بنف
‏would
have prop
people
all
[Silence]
صلى الله عليه وسلم
لا اله الا
‏here
because they underst now all of their id
all of their saints all of the graves
that they worship all of these
superstitions
all of the sers and witches and sayers
all of them are now going to vanish if
they fulfill
لا اله الا الله
لا اله الا
‏more
no more
because of they believe that was
to themselves they
lookight
to Allah is to ma he toure we can't go
to we sinful and we are inad
‏are confineut
[Silence]
and
‏icception
and اله
no more
other will
nextek a quickinder
of
ان شاء الله صلاه الفجر صلاه العشاء
ابو عامر ان شاء الله
صلاه الفجر
5 صلاه العشاء 8ay
sched
والله اعلم وصلى الله وسلم على نبينا محمد
وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين والحمد لله رب
العالمين وجزاكم الله خيرا
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته.
[Arabic recitation]
اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
اشهد ان لا اله
الا الله
اشهد ان
اله الا الله
اشهد ان محمدا
رسول
الله
اشهد ان محمدا
رسول
الله
حي على الصلاه
حي على صلاه
[Silence]
حي على الفلاح
حي على الفلاح يا
[Silence]
الله اكبر الله
الله اكبر
لا
اله
الا الله
[Silence]
ان الحمد لله
نحمده ونستعينه ونستغفره
ونعوذ بالله من شرور انفسنا وسيئات
اعمالنا
من يهده الله فلا مضل له
ومن يضلل فلا هادي له
واشهد ان لا اله الا الله وحده لا شريك له
واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله
يا ايها الذين امنوا اتقوا الله حق تقاته
ولا تموتن الا وانتم مسلمون
يا ايها الناس
اتقوا ربكم الذي خلقكم من نفس واحده
وخلق منها زوجها
وبث منهما رجالا كثيرا ونساء
واتقوا الله الذي تساءلون به والارحام
ان كان عليكم رقيبا
يا ايها الذين امنوا اتقوا الله
وقولوا قولا سديدا
يصلح لكم اعمالكم
ويغفر لكم ذنوب وبكم
ومن يطع الله ورسوله فقد فاز فوزا عظيما
اما بعد فان اصدق الحديث كتاب الله
وخير الهدي هدي محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم
وشر الامور محدثاتها
وكل محدثه بدعه
وكل بدعه ضلاله
وكل كل ضلاله في النار
اما بعد
فيقول الله تعالى في كتابه الكريم
وما تفعلوا من خير يعلمه الله
وتزودوا فان خير الزاد التقوى
الله سبحانه وتعالى
‏over and over
سبحانه وى
and you not you people human being
kindind you do not any good deed
الله
سبحانه وتالى
‏and you will not go unnotic no matter
how
small
brief any you
say this
فمن يعمل مثقال ذره خيرا يرى
الله سبحانه وتعالى
are
‏are
the
will
الله سبحانه وتالى
‏unable
and
angaranteed
any we do even if
الله سبحانه وتعالى
[Silence]
سبحانه وتعالى
الله سبحانه وتعالى
يريد الله بكم اليسر ولا يريد بكم العسر
[Silence]
سبحانه وتعالى
انسان سبحانه وتعالى من جاء بالحسنه فله
عشر امثالها
ومن جاء بالسيئه
فلا يجزى الا مثلها وهم لا يظلمون
سبحانه وتعالى انوز
‏will have
at leastold
and whoever comes having committ
will only count as one and no one will
be wrong
الله سبحانه وتالى made
ان صحيح البخاري ان صحيح مسلم عبد الله بن
عباس رضي الله عنهما
صلى الله عليه وسلم
قال الله عز وجل وجل ان الله كتب الحسنات
والسيئات
ثم بين ذلك فمن هم بحسنه
فعملها كتبت له عشر حسنات
الى 700 ضعف
الى اضعاف كثيره ومن هم بحسنه فلم يعملها
كتبت له حسنه كامله
صلى الله عليه وسلم
‏document each of themously
and inud
he hasanteed who intends to do a good
thing a good deed and then does this
good deed it will be rewarded at least
10fold
up
to us that
inend toes
not
affirm and for him one for intention
even the fleeting int of ours is reward
by
Allah does not
سبحانه وتعالى ما يفعل الله بعذابكم ان
شكرتم وامنتم وكان الله شاكرا عليما الله
سبحانه وتعالى
الله
[Silence]
سبحانه وتالى
الله سبحانه وتالى
‏that each of these gates are enough for
the trav of 40 years you could not cross
across the gate of one of the gates of
paradise 40 years travel from one side
to the other of these gates there are
eight of them and the hell fire it only
has
because we have more of a
‏ell
paradellى
willad
صلى الله عليه وسلم
ابي موسى الاشعري
فقال للجنه انت رحمتي ارحم بك من اشاء
وقال للنار انت عذابي اصيب بك من اشاء
ولكما
علي ملؤها
صلى الله عليه
‏you are my mercy which I show to I
choose and he said to theell you are my
punishment which I afflict upon whom I
choose but both of you I guarantee I
will to capacity
how he fills those two places is very
different because remember when Allah
first created the creation he wrote in a
ان رحم سبقت غضبي
‏and thisat
indeed my mercy
my anger my mercy aff my mercy is upon
my punishment is afflict upon the chosen
few my
exceptionى
say and so how
الله سبحانه وتعالى
صحيح
صلى الله عليه وسلم
[Silence]
الله سبحانه وتعالى
ق
صلى الله عليه وسلم
الله سبحانه وتعالى
‏will
all those for parad will have entered he
will create human beings he will
createin
just to up the remaining areas the
remaining abodes of parad so he fills
the hell fire by making it smaller and
he parad
الله سبحانه وتالى
[Silence]
صلى الله عليه
الله سبحانه وتعالى
الله سبحانه وتالى
harell
سبحانه وتعالى
انس بن مالك
صلى الله عليه وسلم
ل الله افرح بتوبه احدكم او بتوبه عبده
حين يتوب عليه من حين يتوب اليه من احدكم
كان على راحلته بارض فلاه يعني في صحراء
واسعه
قال صلى الله عليه وسلم فانفلت منه راحلته
وعليها طعامه وشرابه
فايس منها واتى الى شجره فاضطجع في ظلها
وهو قد ايس من راحله
فاذا هو بها قائمه بين يديه حتى اخذ
بخطامها فقال من شده الفرح اللهم انت عبدي
وانا ربك اخطا من شده الفرح هكذا يقول صلى
الله عليه وسلم
سبحانه وتعالى
any would
anyal inle of desert and we have our
food and drink on thisel and ourel go
wild
‏areable
areable
صلى الله عليه وسلم
and so this man wasel
it withink
he unable toch it and he comes to a tree
and he lays down in shade and he given
upely hopeless now he has no way
‏die here andises
and there
him until takes and is so happy that he
makaken say and
you are my servant and your lorden
said this because
صلى الله عليه وسلم الله
سبحانه وتعالى
الشيطان
الله سبحانه وتالى
‏have
comer
الله
سبحانه وى
‏isqu
to sin and I have all thisess that
I have created in my life of sinful and
disobedience
what is this one good deed going to do
for
minds
have commed
however
‏entered
them on that
what is that one good do can change
everything
one small minc overled good between you
and Allah where your ‏and your
interectly
in this entire life because of that one
instance in parad for eternity
and the oppos
and so tells us صلى الله عليه وسلم يحرن
احدكم
المعروف
ولو ان يلقى اخاه بوجه طليق
صلى الله عليه وسلم
any
face approaable
صلى الله عليه وسلم
لقد رايت رجلا يتقلب في الجنه في غصن شوك
قطعها او نحاها عن الطريق
صلى الله عليه
‏in parad
and enjoying himself enging himself on
parad and lust and pleasures because of
a little thn bush that was in the path
he kicked it aside on his way and went
on with his life that one little
overlook forgottened
is what ended up here in paradise for
eternity
البروفيت صلى الله عليه وسلم ساد بينما
بغي من بغايا بني اسرائيل
مرت ببئر وعليه كلب ياكل الثرى من العطش
فاستقت له بموقها
فسقته فشكر الله لها فغفر لها هي صلى الله
عليه
اسرائيل
that was going around well. It was so it
was so thirsty. It was eating the dirt
the damp dirt around the well. ‏And she
took her off and took some water from
the well for this and gave thisaygink
and her for her.
اخواني واخواتي في الله
الشيطان
‏overlook a
couldange
do not give up hope because is a book of
hope andal
is im
you are being your potential is almost
incalculable
do not overl a single good deed when you
stand
‏any
for put out of your mind at that moment
pour all of your hearts and hes and
dreams into that one good
because enters parad not based on their
mercy ظمعون
واستغفر الله لي ولكم ولسائر المسلمين
فاستغفروه انه هو الغفور الرحيم
الحمد لله والصلاه والسلام على رسول الله
واشهد ان لا اله الا الله وحده لا شريك له
واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله اللهم صل على
محمد وعلى ال محمد كما صليت على ابراهيم
وعلى ال ابراهيم انك حميد مجيد اللهم بارك
على محمد وعلى ال محمد كما باركت على
ابراهيم وعلى ال ابراهيم في العالمين انك
حميد مجيد اما بعد why از
‏have
to
not because
of
hope
we l
‏I feel nothing I can do will make
meulf
my potential weve given up on ourselves
brothers and sisters we have one chance
when we die when you die when I die and
it is coming sooner rather than later
we canned
‏s
overal
‏around him and said to them
if you
place right now if this man right now
after having died and put in his grave
was someh miraculously given a second
chance he was able to craw out of this
grave and get a second chance at life
what would you do with that second
chance and so they started to list to
him all the things that are on my
‏I woulday more this more would that
more said what sting you you're not
grave he is here your second chance
right now and you're going to fall many
times trying to make yourself better
fall over and over but one of the
reasons our repentance doesn't last is
because we think we need to prepare
ourselves and make ourselves perfect
الله
[Silence]
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين نسال الله سبحانه
وتعالى بمنه وكرمه وجوده ان يبارك لي ولكم
في القران العظيم اسال الله تعالى ان
ينفعني واياكم بما فيه من الايات والذكر
الحكيم اللهم اغفر لنا ذنوبنا وكفر عنا
سيئاتنا وتوفنا مع الابرار ربنا واتنا ما
وعدتنا على رسلك ولا تخزنا يوم القيامه
انك لا تخلف الميعاد اللهم اننا نسالك فعل
الخيرات وترك المنكرات وحب المساكين وان
تغفر لنا وترحمنا وتتوب علينا واذا اردت
بعبادك فتنه فاقبضنا اليك غير مفتونين
اللهم اننا نسالك يا ربنا بمنك وجودك
وكرمك يا رب العالمين نتبتل اليك لما غفرت
لنا ذنوبنا اللهم اغفر لنا ذنوبنا اللهم
اغفر لنا ذنوبنا اللهم علمنا من كتابك ما
جهلنا وذكرنا منه ما نسينا وعلمنا الحكمه
منه اللهم ربنا اننا نعوذ بك من الربا
والزنا والغلى والزلازل والفتن والمحن ما
ظهر منها وما ف وما بطن اللهم اننا عبيدك
بنو عبيدك بنو امائك نواصينا في يدك ماض
فينا حكمك عدل فينا قضاؤك نسالك بكل اسم
هو لك سميت به نفسك او انزلته في كتابك او
علمته احدا من خلقك او استاثرت به في علم
الغيب عندك ان تجعل القران ربيع قلوبنا
ونور صدورنا وجلاء احزاننا وذهاب همومنا
اللهم انصر الاسلام والمسلمين واخذل الشرك
والمشركين وافضح النفاق والمنافقين
اللهم امين وصل اللهم وسلم على نبينا محمد
وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين والحمد لله رب
العالمين
الله اكبر الله اكبر
اشهد ان لا اله الا الله
واشهد ان محمدا رسول الله
حي على الصلاه
حي على الفلاح
قد قامت الصلاه قد قامت الصلاه الله اكبر
الله اكبر لا اله الا الله
استووادوا
‏Stand shoulder toose all the gs your
shoulderseters
and feet of your two nebors on side of
you straighten your straightening the is
part of that has commanded us with and
our will be rewarded based on the
straightness of ours
please double check youres make they
areent so notrup
our
الله سبحانه وتعالى
الله اكبر
من الشيطان
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
اذا زلزلت الارض زلزالها
واخرجت الارض اثقالها
وقال الانسان
ما لها يومئذ
تحدث اخبارها بان ربك اوحى لها يومئذ
يصدر الناس اشتات
ليروا اعمالهم
فمن يعمل مثقال ذره خيرا
يره ومن يعمل مثقال ذره
شرا
يره الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن من حمده
الله اكبر
[Silence]
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
والعصر ان الانسان
لفي خسر الا الذين امنوا وعملوا الصالحات
وتواصوا بالحق وتواصوا
بالصبر
الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن حمده
[Silence]
الله
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
شيخ علي جزاك الله خير
الله
make
them الله
justinder
about the time of the here will be
changing
‏to